this program is being presented to you
by the hereas international winter
school on gravity
and light
welcome back to the double e is
international with disco on gravity and
light
today's sheet is the first actual
physics sheet of the school
so we'll deal with the throttle
space-time
in exercise 1 we will look at the
geodesics in a schwarzschild space time
so we consider a manifold equipped with
a so-called schwarzschild metric
that is given here in the following
we will use this notation the shorthand
notation
and the first question now is
to write down the lagrangian
so the gaussian in its
abstract formulation is given by
a a gamma dot a gamma dot b
for the for this easy case of a
schwarzschild metric
this becomes the lagrangian
l is equal to 1 minus
2 g m divided by
r t prime
squared minus
one over one minus two g m
pi r x uh
not x but r prime squared
minus r squared
theta prime squared
minus r squared sine squared theta
phi prime squared
this was already the first the answer to
the first question
and we move on to the second question
so there it starts with a little remark
that this lagrangian can be parametrized
by lambda
which we will see is just the eigen time
in such a way that the lagrangian is
equal to one
for all lumped down
now there are four euler lagrange
equations for this lagrangian
we want to derive one of them namely
this one with respect to the function t
of lambda
so the euler lagrange equation is zero
is dl by
dt prime
this one derived again by prime so
the prime always indicates derivatives
with respect to this
parameter lambda
and the second term is a del l
by del t
so we see that the lagrangian which we
just wrote down
does not depend on t itself
so del ll by del t is zero
however it is dependent on t
prime so we can derive
del l by del t
prime is just two times
one minus two g m divided by r
g prime
and this expression again derived with
respect
to lambda gives just
two times one minus two
g m divided by r g
double prime
plus four g m divided by
r squared r prime
t prime and this is
already equal to zero
so we can rewrite this equation as t
double prime
plus 2 g
m divided by r squared
of n 1 minus 2 g m over
r of r prime
g prime is 0.
so here we see that we could read of
the christopher symbols for the
schwarzschild metric
in the case that so this is
gamma so this is
two times gamma of
t r t
and of course is equal to two times
gamma t
g r however we don't want to go
further into these christopher symbols
but we rather
would like to show now that the lead
derivative of g with respect to the
vector field
kt which is just given by del by del t
vanishes so
we just take the lead derivative
g a b so
take the lead derivative with respect to
the vector field k t
of g and evaluate at the
components a and b this is
equal to kt
acting on g a b
minus no actually it's a plus here
g m b
and the del del t acting on
oh that is
yeah well that is correct but not del
del t but del
x a acting on the
m's component of kt
and this goes also
the other way around so we take del by
del xp
acting on the m's component of
k
so
in this term we see that this is the
derivative
of g with respect to the function t
however we know that our met the watches
metric
does not depend on our
does not depend explicitly on time on
the time function
so this will give zero
and we also know that the components
kt 0 is 1
while kt 1
2 and 3 are all zero so what we do here
we derive the constant
well that certainly gets zero so this
term goes out
this term goes out this term goes out as
well
so all this is zero
so we showed that the lead derivative of
g with respect to the vector field kt
vanishes so what does this mean well
we have some kind of symmetry here and
of course we will
we see that this symmetry with respect
to
time translations well this gives rise
conserved energy
and the last part of the of this
section here is
to find the conserved quantity so the
explicit form is given by this
expression here and now we want to
derive an expression for this quantity
t prime appearing in the lagrangian
so we see we have k t here but with an
index down that's not a problem
so we see that k t index down
x a prime of lambda
is constant however we're only given
the kt with components up well well
that's not a problem
we just take g a b
k t b
x a prime of lambda
and this only gives us contributions
since the only contribution here from
the kt is for b
equals zero which then also sets a to
zero
due to the special form of our
schwarzschild metric
so after this is g zero zero
times kt zero times
t
this is just 1 minus 2 gm
divided by r g prime of
lambda and this is constant
and now we write this constant as the
square root of
some e which will later turn out to be
the energy
so and then we find that t
prime of lambda can be rewritten as
the square root of e divided by
1 minus 2 gm divided by r
this was the first part of this exercise
now we see that also this metric
fulfills
so-called spherical symmetry
that is the lead derivative of g with
respect to these vector fields which we
already know from
the tutor from the last tutorial that
delineative vanishes
so which physical quantity is conserved
by this symmetry
well that's rather easy since we know
that this
is just so in quantum mechanics this
would be the
angular so this would be the algebra for
angular momentum and indeed
angular mention is conserved here
and to fix angular momentum we need
two vector fields
that fill that fixed direction
and one vector field
that fixes the absolute value
of angular momentum
so the first two of these vector fields
x1 and x2
they fix the motion to a plane of
constant theta
and if we have found such a plane of
we can of course turn
or turn our system of reference in such
a way
that we end up at theta is equal to pi
half which makes life much easier since
then all these sine
squared or sine theta that appear are
just one and we don't need
to carry them through anymore which i
said can set them to one
and of course we can always turn our
system of reference such a way
that if we have fixed ourselves to
a plane of constant theta so that we can
we can turn around our system of
reference to theta is equal to pi half
but how can we now derive an expression
for the remaining term
phi prime of lambda well that's not a
problem we already
saw how to derive the conserved quantity
for a symmetry
on the last exercise or in the last
question
so we recall that
we need x3 index
down x prime
a no x a
prime
of lambda is constant
we can rewrite this to
g a b x 3 with index b
up now and the x a
prime of lambda is constant
so now we can take okay
x3 only which was exactly
del by del phi has only
a non-vanishing b equal 3 component
which then means we get that g 3 3
x 3 b and
phi prime of lambda is constant
and this constant we like to call
minus j
so which will turn out to be the angular
momentum
so g3 3 was just minus
r squared sinus squared
theta however we know that
theta is equal to pi half and thus the
sine squared is just one
and for that we find that phi prime of
lambda is equal
to j over r squared
which is a nice formula in fact
and now we are prepared to look at the
lagrangian again
so we now use the fact that the
lagrangian is equal to one over the
whole parametrization
so the lagrangian itself is a conserved
quantity
now we want to insert all the previously
obtained results and
then we'll see what we get out
so we have one is equal
to the lagrangian is equal to
1 minus 2 g m divided by
r and now we insert
t prime so this is just e divided by
1 minus 2 g m over r
squared
we get a minus sign a one
divided by one minus two g m over
r r prime squared
we can't substitute anything in here
because we have no conserved quantity
for
r prime however in the case
in the next term that which would be
theta prime
we know that this term vanishes since we
say since we have
our motion in a plane of constant theta
and the last term contained phi prime
well we just we just found the formula
how to replace this phi
prime by j squared so phi prime squared
is just
j squared over r to the fourth power
and now we substitute all the terms and
can
and can put them all together and we
will find that
one is equal to e or divided by one
minus two
g m over r
minus one
over one minus two g m divided by
r r prime squared
minus j squared
divided by r squared
and now we put all terms
that contain e which is only the first
one here
to one side and all the other ones to
the other side
so we find that this is e is e is equal
to
one minus two g m
by r times 1
plus j squared divided by r squared
plus
and r prime squared term
so the result will be that e is equal to
r
prime squared
plus 1 minus 2 gm
divided by r
plus j squared divided by r squared and
the last term minus
2g m j squared divided by r to the power
of 3.
and now the last question asks us to
interpret the terms that appear in this
expression
so on the left side this is
the total energy total energy e
so we know that quite well r prime
squared
well that is just some kind of kinetic
term
so we have not introduced a mass here so
we have
unit mass m equals to one
then this term here the one is just the
mass term
so the relativistic correct mass term
which would be
m c squared however we set both m and c
to one so we just get the 1 here
now we have minus 2 gm divided by r
well you should know that this is just
the newtonian gravitational potential
the next term j squared divided by r
squared well this is just a contribution
due to the angular momentum
that is also quite standard
but now this last term here this is the
interesting
one and this one
then indeed turns out to be the
correction term from gr
and you see this is divided so
you have constants here
in the numerator and in the denominator
you have
r to the power of three so
this term will contribute
when r is small and that indeed is
of course the physical relevance of
schwarzschild space time
you don't far far away from
the player for example black hole
you don't see much effects that are
different from the usual ones the usual
classical
picture however if you go near the black
hole of course
the motion of your particle on the
curved space there is quite different
and there this term gives us the correct
equations so we see we can interpret all
these terms
all the four terms here are purely
classical
kinetic term a mass term the classical
gravitational potential and contribution
of angular momentum
but only the last one really says okay
this is
the correction to the motion
that comes from gr and corrects our
classical motion
so this is the first exercise of this
sheet
and there will be one more exercise
which will deal with gravitational
redshift
also an important effect
appearing in general relativity
so we consider a space standards
equipped with a schwarzschild metric
as well as two observers one and two
that are at rest in their respective
system of reference that means
their coordinates are theta and phi
they don't change they only move in time
the observers sit at the same theta and
phi
for simplicity while the
radial coordinates are 1 and r is
smaller than r2
so you want to derive first an
expression for t
prime using the lagrangian from the
previous exercise
so we remember we have that the
lagrangian is equal to
one and the first contribution
was one minus two g m divided by
r t prime squared
now there would be more terms concern
having
r prime theta prime and phi prime
however we know since the observers
don't move
well these terms get kicked out
so this is indeed the whole expression
we need to look at here
and this means that t prime is equal to
over square root of minus of 1 minus 2
gm
divided by r
now observer 1 emits photons that
observer 2 detects
the gap between two photon emissions is
delta lambda one
so what this means is in physical terms
observer one emits photons
and between two photo emissions
in you have the interval delta lambda
one in eigen time
so so one emits
after each period delta lambda 1 a photo
however observer 2 maybe sees this
these this length differently
and we want to calculate this
so of course there our
formula for t prime derived in the first
question will prove useful
we see for fixed r
we have a fixed r here so the whole
right side
does not depend on lambda
so we can just integrate this and we
will find that
delta t so in the coordinate time
that this is just so 4 1
for observer 1 this is 1 over
square root of 1 minus 2 gm divided by
r1
delta lambda 1
and of course for observer 2 this is
delta t2 this is just 1 over
square root of 1 minus 2 gm
divided by r2
delta lambda 2.
so now we have to consider these two
delta t1 and delta t2 so both
distances in coordinate type and
therefore we
it's the best if we draw
a space time diagram of this whole
situation
so we have up here is the time
and here we say that there goes
the radial coordinate so we have
observer 1 sitting at r1 observer 2
sitting at r2
and the world line it looks just like
that as the coordinates
in space so r theta and phi never
change this is the world line
of these two obser of both also these
are the word lines of both observers
now observer one emits a photon here
and a photon here
so this is delta t1
so and now we see
okay this goes some way for example
this way all the way here
where observer 2 m detects
this photon and now we wonder how does
this
path how does the word line of the
photon
look like if it is emitted up here
and now we use our knowledge from the
first exercise
we know that
the schwarzschild space time has a
symmetry with respect to time
translations
since the vector field k t which was
just del by del t
was a killing vector field
so we know that this the situation
from here from the first dimension to
the second
didn't change but for a constant offset
delta
t1 in coordinate time but
on r or something else nothing has
changed on the other coordinates
so the situation up here is just the
same and we get just the
same curve parallel up here
to this to the second detection by
observer two
so these two lines
can be said to be parallel
so their distance the distance between
two points of equal r is always the same
as delta t1
but you know also that this here is
delta t2
well but if this holds here for that the
distance
in space time between every two points
here
that have the same r is always delta t
one
well then delta t one is obviously
equal to delta t two
oh k this is good we find that delta
lambda2 then is just
ah no we have to write it a little
differently
so we just say that this is delta lambda
1 which will prove
easier in the next exercise we do it
this way
that this is exactly a big square root
one minus two g m
divided by r one over
one minus two g m divided by
r two and this
is times delta lambda 2.
so you get this fact so
the emission so the
dm so observer one emits
photons with a
delay of in its eigen time of delta
lambda one
however observer 2 detects these
with this factor here
so he picks up such a factor here and
now we look
how does this look at the at the
frequency level
so consider the ratio of the frequencies
omega 2
divided by omega 1.
well it's quite obvious to see that this
just corresponds to the case that delta
lambda 1 is divided by delta lambda 2.
oh well that is easy this is just this
big square root we have here
this one minus 2 gm divided by r1
divided by 1 minus 2gm divided by
r2
and indeed since we have
r1 is smaller than r2
we see that
the numerator up here
is smaller than the denominator
so this will be smaller than one
which corresponds to omega 2 being
smaller than omega 1 or
for wavelength
we know that the observed wavelengths
for our for observer 2
is so
for so i call the wavelength here not
lambda since lambda is already
already given but we will call it
well i would call it just mu
we then know that the wavelength
observed by observer 2
mu 2 is larger than mu 1
well in larger wavelength we always call
that this is more red
so we have a red shift
now we look at what happens if observer
2 is being approximately at infinity
well observer 2 being approximately
infinity
for a schwarzschild space time means
that he is
sitting in the approximately flat space
so we can just take the limit of the
expression for small
r2 well then the denominator just kicks
out here
and we find that omega 2 divided by
omega 1
for r2 to infinity
is just square root of 1 minus 2 gm
divided by r1
and now the second special case is what
happens if we send
r1 to the schwarzschild radius rs is to
gm
but you see that then the numerator
becomes very very little so
the observed frequencies
so omega 2
grows larger and larger
the more r1 is near the schwarzschild
radius
and of course if we are exactly at
so the redshift is even stronger and
stronger
so the wavelength are so you observe
very very large wavelength
and if you go to the schwarzschild
radius
so if you sit now exactly at the
schwarzschild radius
this whole formula then breaks down you
can't observe a frequency then anymore
so you can observe any wavelength and
set and so
you can't bring information
from the schwarzschild radius or even
from below the 30 radius outside this is
not possible
you have to sit above the schwarzschild
radius
and with this
we want to close this tutorial
and we hope to see you next time